we have a very special guest in the
studio Arena congratulations first of
all win but with the black pieces so
before you unravel the mysteries of your
game today and your preparation please
tell us how do you feel is it an
advantage to play in the home turf
oh well we'll see when the tournament is
over you know
um but in general of course I'm happy to
play in St Louis
um any any kind of tournament whether
it's like a national event or an
International Event
um and yeah of course I don't have to
deal with the jet lag you know that is
always nice right it's like someone
who's often like had to go and play in
Europe it's definitely nice to have some
events at home but I think maybe maybe
the the bigger Advantage is just that
like how much I love St Louis you know
because I've been coming here you know
since 2009 multiple times a year so I
feel like really comfortable here and
I'm always happy to come back
okay so let's have a look at your game
first of all tell us a little bit about
the opening have were you expecting this
variation and what were the critical
moments yeah I mean I was expecting an
open Sicilian as the most likely
um line so it was kind of like you know
she's quite principled in her opening
choices with white so like the Rouser
variation not a surprise we've had that
they're um in games between ourselves
before so I mean it was only a question
of like you know which let's say Rouser
was I going to pick right and um so I
went for something I've played this line
sometimes in the past
yeah I mean F4 she's played a few times
so like there was nothing really
unexpected like it's just about like you
basically have to agree that you're
gonna play this structure of position
with a double death pawns you know I
mean of course the computer is always
going to give an edge to White
um but what I found in the game I mean
it's like it's a really rich position
and I actually enjoyed playing it
okay so let's have a look so we're not
here yeah it's where the structures
change so you you're forced to take GTX
F6 of course otherwise a weight is taken
on G6 F5 H5 yeah she's played F5 before
right so like that's also you know just
the most direct move um in this position
and okay I would say that H5 is um it's
an option for black there's a lot of
ways black can play this position so
this was just something that I had like
uh picked out for today you know and uh
well I wanted to come back to this
position and actually I thought that
Queen V6 is a mistake because Jean say
is such a dynamic player so after Queen
B6 the game went your way so what do I
think so look at let me tell you
actually what I thought was the first
critical moments of the game
um so it was okay we can go quickly
through like Queen A5 like after King V1
Queen A5 okay so Queen A5 is like it's a
typical move for these positions right
like pinning the Knight so that she
cannot transfer it from to E2 so you're
like kind of holding off this maneuver
so she played Bishop D3 it's one of the
possible moves I castled queen side Rook
ht1 yeah very natural centralization
King B7 and yeah the reason the king is
going to be seven is to sometimes give
the queen these Queen B6 ideas so Queen
F2 Rook C8 and like really my big think
in the game came after she played Knight
E2
um because here like okay on one hand
you're thinking okay Knight B4 A3 Knight
takes D3 Rook D3 do you want that
position yeah with the two Bishops
versus the two knights I kind of decided
I didn't yeah I see I see that was
correct at some point I was just like
there's so many
um you know ideas here for why to
basically improved her Rook
um sometimes there's even ideas like
Queen H4 E5 like blowing up the center
so
um so I thought for a long time here and
ultimately I went for this movie E5 and
I was quite happy with this it wasn't
the first move that came to my mind
um but you know normally you're not
supposed to really play this move if the
Knight has access to D5 but here I
realized like if she goes Knight C3
Knight B4 actually seems to work out in
terms of
um tempos you know because Rook takes C3
is coming and yeah let's say three Rook
C3 if she actually takes yeah well she
takes on B4 then Queen B4 kind of holds
everything even after Queen G2 Rook uh
yeah like she can't pin me because
um Queen D2 and Rook hc8 you know and I
I don't lose my Rook basically there's
no way she can win it because even after
King C1 there's like Queen A4 and
there's Checkmate
yeah you know I mean that's what I mean
like there were some cool things
involved and I really felt like this
movie E5 was like really an important
decision right because you're changing
the pawn structure obviously you're also
keeping out the knight from D4 and F4
um so I see the computer is not super
impressed with this move but you know
honestly I felt like it was it was a
decent move and it kind of like that's
where the game started to change you
know
so she went um 90 C1 quite quickly
Queen B6 yeah and I mean she has a big
Choice here I did feel like you said
Queen trade just in general like Not a
Bad Thing against an attacking player
right so
um and I really actually just thought
the end game was was not going to be a
problem for black
so but did she have an option like of
like keeping the questions on the board
yeah Queen D2 I mean
um what was I gonna do here yeah I mean
I didn't have any specific plans to be
honest they can oh like at some point
you can think about about even like well
okay maybe not before actually Knight A5
wasn't one idea that there you go now I
remember some of my thoughts Knight A5
yeah and um yeah you know the night can
come to C4 sometimes or even just before
maybe
um maybe play Rook C7 Rook C8
um but yeah it felt kind of normal okay
so Queen B6 so what did you feel here
were you happy after yeah I felt I
didn't think that I should be worse like
I wasn't exactly sure what I was going
to do on Knight E2 but I felt like I was
gonna have a way to keep her night out
of D5
and then that was my next big thing of
the game when I found this bishop d897
which you know again I was quite happy
to see that idea because the Knight on
E7 is doing a good job but the bishop on
C7 is also not so terrible
okay I mean you have to walk us through
through the most important moments of
the game because like we have very
little time because I think they I
wanted to ask you here it was very well
one of the crucial moments of the game
because your opponent sacrificed in
exchange look you didn't take it yeah
what did you think here yeah okay so I
took the night right so it's basically
the question should I take should I I
mean why didn't take it I mean I guess I
was just like you know white takes with
a knight plays Bishop D3 Bishop E4 and I
was kind of like afraid that um you know
this there would be some big
compensation here you know but I see I
see there's that I also thought like
I'll probably be able to take the Rook
later which didn't work out yeah no I
mean definitely I knew that this this
moment like I kind of messed it up okay
and then uh well I think it's a human
decision because it's not easy to valid
if well there could be a fortress on the
white squares so let's have a look at
this very important moment where your
opponent took an F7 did you have a
feeling here that you were already
winning
yeah I mean I guess like it's much
easier to play this position on
intuition for black than for white right
and it's kind of like what I felt was
like she was kind of trying to play on
intuition this end game but the problem
is it's a lot harder to do that as white
you know white has like specific
problems to solve black has very few
things they need to think about except
how to promote the age pawn and like
make mating threats to the white King
right so when she took the pawn it was
like it didn't shock me or anything
because I just felt like she was kind of
in this mode right like she went for the
a pawn she abandoned the age Pawn so I
mean I didn't know like if this was the
big mistake or it had already happened
but like I knew that you know it's going
to be um very uncomfortable for white to
play yes and here you made a few precise
moves so uh okay each one of course yeah
my favorite move was Bishop D4 in the
end you know that was that was one thing
I actually stopped to calculate I don't
know if King C3 is as good Bishop D4 I
was like oh I'm threatening Checkmate
Rook H1 and then I'm also threatening uh
rugby two Rook C2 winning the bishop and
she cannot here's the line that I
calculated I'll actually show you the
nice one
um so let's say she plays like should B5
right Bishop B5 check so I was gonna go
King C3 and okay so I'm threatening
um
well let's say she goes Rook d8 yeah and
so basically I just go Rook H1 King A2
and H2 because now I got her Bishop off
the diagonal and the problem is
um yeah I mean if basically if she's
going Rook h8 then just King C2 is going
to be made and here
um okay yeah here I guess I just move my
rook and promote
thank you very much we have to go see
you tomorrow thank you guys uh
congratulations to you Arena